temps
ravi de vous retrouver sur lcp public
sénat pour cette nouvelle édition d'
europe hebdo présenté depuis le
parlement européen à bruxelles cette
semaine l'europe sans vol six pays
européens ont uni leurs forces et leurs
technologies pour mettre au point un
projet de drone européen de combat du
futur
vous voyez ici ce démonstrateur de drone
sur la base aérienne d'istres on en
parlera tout à l'heure avec deux invités
mais d'abord la question de la semaine
existe-t-il un tourisme social en europe
une décision de la cour européenne de
justice relance le débat explications en
images
12 novembre 2014 les juges de luxembourg
tranche un état membre de l'union
européenne peut refuser des prestations
aux migrants qui pratiquent le tourisme
social viser ceux et celles qui se
rendent dans un pays européen uniquement
pour toucher les aides
la cour européenne se prononce sur le
cas d'une ressortissante roumaine
installé à leipzig en allemagne
elle demande des allocations chômage
pour élever son fils refusé par l'
agence locale pour l'emploi
les juges des voûtes alors la plaignante
en rappelant la directive européenne sur
les citoyens de l'union
une personne qui ne travaille pas doit
avoir des ressources suffisantes pour
vivre dans un autre état membre
oui mais voilà en europe certains pays
sont plus généreux que d'autres à
londres la question fait rage les
conservateurs au pouvoir veulent couper
les aides au logement et au chômage
accordée au citoyen non britannique
en france la constitution garantit au
contraire une égalité de traitement
les prestations sont donc accessibles à
tous quelle que soit la nationalité du
demandeur
mais la décision de la cour européenne
fait polémique
il faut que nos gouvernants se
saisissent de cette jurisprudence pour
faire en sorte que nous prenions des
décisions très fortes
aujourd'hui je trouve ça indécent au
moment où un certain nombre des millions
et des millions de gens fuient à la fois
le réchauffement climatique puisqu'il ya
trois fois plus de réfugiés liée au
réchauffement climatique aux conflits
fuient la pauvreté fui la misère en
période de restrictions budgétaires
des voix s'élèvent sur le continent pour
revoir le principe de libre circulation
pilier de la construction européenne
c'est la question n'est pas réglée à
temps elle pourrait bien devenir
explosive
un député européen nous a rejoint robert
rochefort bonjour bonjour vous êtes
français membre du groupe de l'alliance
des démocrates et des libéraux pour
l'europe et votre commission c'est celle
du marché intérieur et des consommateurs
alors je reprends ma question est ce que
ce tourisme social
c'est un fantasme ou une réalité est ce
que c'est une pratique réelle ou un
phénomène imaginaire alors déjà arrêtons
d'appeler ça du tourisme social sont
insupportables
oui parce que pour moi le tourisme
social ce sont les villages vacances
familles c'est-à-dire tout ce que les
clubs d'entreprises ont fait il ya 20
ans il ya trente ans ce sont les
eurocritique ceux qui veulent casser
l'europe qui appelle ça du tourisme
social revanche qu'il y ait un sujet qui
est celui de savoir dans quelles
conditions et comment on donne des
prestations sociales aux migrants ça
c'est un vrai sujet et je trouve que la
décision qui a été prise par la cour est
une décision raisonnable qui d'ailleurs
ne fait que reprendre ce que déjà les
textes ont institué et en tout état de
cause il vaut mieux prévenir que guérir
les faire en sorte qu' effectivement on
est maintenant une jurisprudence qui
soient rappelés et qu'ils soient claires
et bien écoutez ça je trouve que c'est
positif
est ce que ça peut créer faire
jurisprudence comme un oui oui oui
justement il faut que nous serions
capables de montrer aux eaux aux
europhobe au delà même des britanniques
dont on vient d'entendre quelques échos
à tous ceux qui veulent casser l'europe
il faut que nous nous soyons capables
nous de dire que nous sommes des gens
responsables nous ne sommes pas pour
comment dire un laxisme généralisé nous
sommes pour de l'humanisme
vous savez que cette disposition
concerne les migrants intra européens
qui sont entre trois mois et cinq ans de
président de présence dans un autre
territoire que celui de leur territoire
d'origine donc on est sur un sas de
transition et il me semble logique de
dire que ben nous devons réguler les
choses
et effectivement toutes prestations
sociales n'est pas valable pour tout le
monde
en tout moment parce que comme l'avait
dit en son temps michel rocard pour pour
d'autres situations l'europe et chacun
10 à ne peuvent pas accueillir la misère
du monde il faut être généreux humanisme
et raisonnable alors comment on peut
être à la fois généreux et humaniste et
réseaux
c'est pas facile la vie surtout en
période de rigueur budgétaire
justement il faut avoir des règles qui
sont des règles extrêmement strictes
il faut considérer que dans la période
de transition quand un étranger un non
résident arrive dans un autre pays de
l'union européenne j'ai même encore du
mal à appeler le mot étranger mais en
fait c'est comme ça et vous faites
référence à aux citoyens des pays et la
voilà mais qui sont effectivement il se
trouve que l'union européenne et la
liberté de circulation s'applique un
européenne c'est-à-dire les roumains et
les bulgares pour les fouiller alors les
roumains et les bulgares attention vous
savez qu'il ya des endroits où les
roumains et les bulgares sont plus des
contributeurs à la richesse produite que
des consommateurs d'ailleurs d'une façon
générale il faut il faut bien qu'à c'est
une idée qui serait une idée fausse
c'est que les les personnes qui passent
d'un état à l'autre sont globalement
plutôt producteurs de richesses dans
l'état dans lequel il arrive que
consommateur de prestations que ferez
vous dit c'est qu'il n'y a pas d'un côté
les profiteurs et de l'autre les
travailleurs et qui a plus de deux
personnes qui se déplacent en europe
pour aller travailler bien chabure
l'essentiel cela devrait aller
travailler
et comme vous le savez quand on se
déplace la plupart du temps on est déjà
adulte même sur les enfants avec soi
donc tout le coût de l'éducation a déjà
été porté par le pays dont vous venez et
on se déplace rarement à plus de 60 ans
donc on est on est actif alors
évidemment avec le contexte de chômage
dans lequel nous sommes
c'est pas vrai pour tout le monde en
toutes circonstances il ya des grandes
différences selon les régions
mais je crois que cet arrêt de la cour
amène un élément de bon sens je pense
qu'il serait logique effectivement qu'il
fasse jurisprudence et que les
différents états européens appliquent
d'une certaine façon cette règle tous
uniformément et ce message s'adresse
aussi aux britanniques qui ne veulent
pas appliquer leurs équivalents à
restreindre la liberté oui c'est alors
que justement pour ce qui est des
britanniques c'est à eux que je faisais
référence
vous savez que les roumains et les
bulgares en britain en royaume uni sont
plus contributeurs qu'ils ne sont
comment dire bénéficiaires de
prestations sont donc comme vous dites
le tourisme social cc n'appelez pas ça
du tourisme social s'il vous plaît c'est
un message bien compris les questions
internationales sont aussi dans
l'actualité
ce que l'europe est pressée d'agir
notamment sur le front ukrainien
elle est pressée surtout de parler à la
russie et bien c'est justement le
leitmotiv de la nouvelle chef de la
diplomatie européenne écouter
des instruments les moyens que l'europe
a utilisé jusqu'à présent ne sont pas un
objectif en soi juste un moyen de
pression supplémentaire sur la russie je
parle des sanctions économiques mène 17
h
les discussions que nous avons
maintenant vista permettre de rétablir
le dialogue avec la russie parce que la
russie fait partie du problème mais
c'est aussi la solution du problème
porte alors être ferme mais pas trop
avec la russie c'est apparemment la
nouvelle ligne de conduite de federica
mort et guérini est ce que c'est la
bonne méthode
non la bonne méthode c'est être ferme
mais effectivement cherché à dialoguer
même s'il le faut d'une façon comment
dire pas totalement transparente et pas
sur la place publique
il faut absolument que l'union
européenne donc madame guérini mais
aussi puisque ça a été décidé ainsi
le ministre des affaires étrangères
allemand auquel je pense qu'il serait
logique que ceux ci le ministre polonais
ministre français comme ç'avait été au
début de la crise ukrainienne il faut
absolument ne pas couper les ponts avec
la russie il faut absolument trouver une
solution qui soit une solution non pas
consistant à couper la poire en deux
mais il faut qu effectivement l'ukraine
face probablement un pas un peu plus
supplémentaire vers ce qu'on appelle le
fédéralisme qui d'ailleurs est dans le
prolongement de l'autonomie que ce pays
avait déjà accordé un certain nombre de
dande enclave ou de territoire en
particulier russophone mais il faut
effectivement non il faut être ferme
avec avec les ruelles mais il faut
absolument trouver un accord et alors
c'est un peu contradictoire quand même
pas alors on est ce qu'on peut quand
même dialoguer en continuant à appliquer
des sanctions qui pénalise quand même
beaucoup l'économie russe oui elle est
justement c'est ça qui est important
c'est qu'on voit bien que l'économie
russe commence maintenant à être
atteinte par par ces sanctions
mais il faut faire une différence entre
des des sanctions aujourd'hui très très
court terme et le fait de trouver une
solution de moyen et de long terme qui
est absolument indispensable vous savez
si on donne le sentiment à monsieur
poutine de flancher sous prétexte qu'on
veut un accord avec lui on
un perdant donc il faut rester ferme
mais dire en même temps c'est pas
contradictoire dire en même temps que
nous savons que l'avenir passe par un
accord avec lui et surtout ne pas
renvoyer les russes dans une sorte de
recherche d'alliances de l'autre côté
consistant à penser qu'il n'y avait que
l'aco avec la chine que les russes
peuvent s'entendre maintenant l'europe a
autant besoin de la russie que la
réserve en europe pour vous je pense que
la russie a plus besoin de l'europe mais
nous avons aussi besoin de la russie
c'est un débouché pour nos exportations
les besoins d'infrastructures sont très
importants que les européens vous
entende merci beaucoup d'avoir été
arrêté devant et dos
robert rochefort place tout de suite au
reportage il ressemble à une soucoupe
volante mais il fait bien partie de ce
monde sur notre code ne rompt le projet
de futur drone européen
fruit d'une coopération entre six
nations et bien le nord on a fait ces
essais dans le sud de la france marion
lefebvre et juliette thurette l'ont
rencontré reportage
voici le ne rompt il est unique c'est un
démonstrateur technologique les
d'un drone de combat furtif
il préfigure l'avenir
noront est un programme européen qui a
été lancée en 2006 avec six nations
partenaires qui partageait cette idée
commune de l'avenir de l'aéronautique de
combat en matière de drones de combat
l'italie l'espagne la suède la grèce à
la suisse et la france se sont réunis
autour de ce projet dont dassault pilote
la réalisation pendant plusieurs années
les ingénieurs ont planché sur leurs
ordinateurs aux quatre coins de l'europe
puis les premières maquettes ont été
testé en soufflerie avant l'assemblage
du drone 12 mètres cinquante d'envergure
7 tonnes au total de bombe de 250 kg en
soute
le voici à istres c'est ici que le
noront a effectué son premier vol le 1er
décembre 2012
patrick castagnos et le directeur des
essais en vol depuis son premier envol
il supervise les essais notamment sur la
furtivité car l'un des défis a été de
rendre le neurons invisible avec un
avion qui est de la taille de mirage
on cherche du point de vue signature à
être l'équivalent de un stylo un petit
oiseau
il a fallu créer une nouvelle structure
d'avion le neuro est parfaitement lisse
uniforme sans aspérité pas une antenne
ni un capteur extérieur
tout a été intégré à l'intérieur de sa
structure le moteur est réellement à
cacher à l'intérieur de l'avion et donc
c'est une prouesse technique que de
réussir à faire fonctionner un moteur
derrière une longue entrée d'air aux
formes très torturé pour cacher ce
moteur derrière le nom se cache un
pilote automatique mais aussi et surtout
un pilote au sol
la difficulté pour lui c'est qu'il ne va
pas être à bord de l'avion et donc
pouvoir utiliser tous ses sens pour pour
contrôler la machine
on parle souvent de qu'un pilote excusez
moi l'expression ou pilotes aux fesses
mais ça veut dire bien qu'il a des
retours sensorielle physique quand il
fait évoluer son avion il ressent le
facteur de charge il ressent les
mouvements tout ça en étant à 100 km de
l'avion dans une station sol immobile
sans fenêtre où
dispose que d'écran pour observer le
comportement et pour cela une salle
d'écouté veille sur tous les paramètres
de l'avion
c'était avant tout de vérifier que les
industriels maîtrisait ce niveau de
technologie qu à un coût raisonnable
donc abordable un jour dans un programme
maintenant il faut passer à l'étape
d'après l'étape d'après c'est de faire
rentrer les opérationnels dans la
réflexion eux mêmes ont leurs propres
réflexions de ce que pourrait être la
guerre de demain les conflits de demain
pour regarder à partir des technologies
dont nous avons la maîtrise
l'adaptation est l'adéquation entre ces
technologies et leurs prévisions du
besoin opérationnel pour savoir si on
peut en faire un programme c'est
opérationnel comme la direction générale
de l'armement qui pilote le projet
suivent de très près ces essais même
s'il ne rompt est unique
il préfigure l'avenir des avions de
combat à long terme
aujourd'hui on a des essais relativement
confidentielle en matière de furtivité
qui donne également pleinement
satisfaction et donc les essais vont se
poursuivre jusqu'à fin 2015
dans le même temps nous préparons un
avenir opérationnel l'objectif commun
que nous partageons donc avec les
britanniques c'est de faire en sorte que
des drones de combat puissent voler à
l'horizon 2030 pour mener à ce groupe de
combat elle les français les anglais ont
signé un partenariat de deux ans c'est
le programme f casse f casse comme futur
système aérien de combat c'est pour le
moment une étude de faisabilité mais il
présage sans doute le lancement du
développement et de la réalisation d'un
drone opérationnel
les drones sont ils l'avenir de la
défense européenne pour en parler de
députés deux invités pardon sont avec
nous un député arnaud danjean bonjour à
jour vous êtes donc député du parti
populaire européen
vous êtes membre de la commission des
affaires étrangères et spécialisée dans
les questions de défense et à vos côtés
nicolas gros verheyde journaliste à
ouest france et auteur du blog de
bruxelles 2 qui nous dit où chaque jour
sur les questions de défense européenne
une question à vous arnaud danjean
l'europe était jusque là considérée
comme hors jeu dans le domaine des
drones est ce que ce projet ce
démonstrateur de drone n'aurons peut lui
permettre de revenir dans la course
ou est-ce que c'est déjà trop tard obama
retard considérable puisque même les
armées européennes aujourd'hui sur les
théâtres d'opérations font appel à des
matériels américains y compris la france
qui a toujours été si réticente et on la
comprend a acheté sur étagères comme on
dit des produits américains a été obligé
de le faire pour ses opérations et agen
c'est à dire acheter ça veut dire
acheter des produits américains
voilà et sans technologie européenne et
c'est ce qui est arrivé à la france avec
ses opérations au sahel où sont engagés
aujourd'hui des drones d'origine
américaine donc on a un retard
considérable maintenant il ya quand même
de là vers une vertu évidente dans ses
projets faut bien souligner quand même
pour nos téléspectateurs ça a été dit
dans le reportage que le nord on n'est
pas un drone en tant que tel c'est une
c'est une plate forme c'est un
démonstrateur technologique qui
préfigure ce que peut être l'avion de
combat de demain qu'ils soient sans
pilote
un drone ou éventuellement même avec
pilote donc les projets de drones
proprement dit c'est un peu autre chose
c'est le f casse franco britannique dont
on parle et puis c'est l'impulsion
industriels et politiques qui a été
lancé à la fin de l'année dernière en
disant il faut qu'à l'horizon 2020
l'europe ceux d'autres se dote d'un
drone dit mâle moyenne altitude longue
endurance ce dont elle ne dispose pas
aujourd'hui
et là c'est encore d'autres industriels
même si on retrouve dassault qui
commence aussi à travailler sur ce
projet mais le retard est déjà
conséquent le retard est déjà conséquent
nicolas gros verheyde les drones en a
parlé récemment lors d'un conseil
européen les états plusieurs états se
sont engagés à donner la priorité à ses
drones qui permettent d'acquérir des
renseignements essentiels qui peuvent
être utiles par exemple dans
dans la région du sahel est ce que il ya
une volonté politique pour faire avancer
pour avancer ensemble dans ce domaine
est elle réelle volonté politique mais
comme disait arnaud danjean il ya un
retard il n'y a même pas un retard
simplement au niveau industriel il ya un
retard à tous niveaux même pour la
législation européenne en matière
d'insertion des drones dans l'espace
européen donc quelque chose d'assez
classique qui n'engagent rien qui
n'engage aucun financement
on a commencé à découvrir le problème on
va dire quasiment il ya un an je dis pas
que le problème n'était pas identifié et
on n'a même pas commencé
on a commencé à travailler on n'a même
pas encore la législation c'est à dire
le retard il est immense en gros on a
vingt pour moi on a vingt ans de retard
parce que un projet qui commence il ya
quelques années comme le projet d'union
ça veut dire qu'effectivement il va
aboutir d'ici une dizaine d'années le
projet européen dont parlait arnaud
danjean sur le drone plus d'observations
donc notre combat c'est 2020 donc ça
veut dire et encore c'est très loin ça
veut pas dire qu'on ne pourra pas
rattraper le retard
on est partis globalement avec 20 ans de
retard donc là on les étapes se
succèdent mais il n'y a pas de miracle
la conception d'un drone s'est mis ou
d'un matériel militaire c'est minimum en
gros 10 ans entre les premiers projets
un peu sérieux c'est à dire qu'on fait
le cahier des charges et l'arrivée sur
sur le sur le
le tarmac de l'aéroport militaire en
usage ou en opération s'avère pendant 10
ans on va devoir acheter sur les tâches
à leur avantage en disant c'est très
long alors que les armées françaises par
exemple ont un besoin de drones
maintenant immédiat pour par exemple qui
pourraient être utiles notamment dans la
lutte au sahel est par exemple aussi
peut-être pourquoi pas pour lutter
contre l'état islamique
ce qui veut dire quoi ce qui veut dire
que faute de solution européenne à
portée de main c'est à dire que les pays
vont continuer à acheter sur étagères
comme vous dites acheter des drones tout
près aux américains bien sûr rien bien
sûr c'est quelque chose qui
stratégiquement est très dérangeant pour
les européens j'allais dire
singulièrement pour les français qui
sont toujours à la pointe de la
revendication de ce qu'on appelle
l'autonomie stratégique européenne qui à
notre avis une très noble cause avec a
merdé en achetant les drones reaper aux
aléas elle a perdu elle avait ce besoin
opérationnel on a perdu comme le disait
nicolas gros verheyde on a perdu en
amont c'est cette neurons ça a été lancé
en 2003 les l'idée même du projet ça
fait déjà plus de dix ans mais les
décisions de se doter d'un drone n'ont
pas été prises récemment et donc on a un
retard considérable et il faut il faut
il faut combler et donc cédé solution
par défaut qui sont qui sont choisis
mais qui traduisent quand même une vraie
perte de souveraineté qui traduisent une
vraie perte d'ambition aussi pour pour
la france et pour l'europe
on est en train d'essayer de combler ce
retard c'est quand même très compliqué
on peut on peut revenir sur les raisons
tout ça il ya beaucoup de raisons faut
pas oublier malgré tous les problèmes
financiers parce que les états européens
en crise le développement d'un programme
militaire ça demande beaucoup d'argent
en recherche même si la table s'appelle
justement l'internet sa demande des
investisseurs métro de façon très
concrète plusieurs dizaines voire
centaines de millions d'euros
très peu d'états sont prêts à le faire
certains l'ont fait comme l'allemagne
pour européaniser des drones américains
dont il voulait se doter
ça a été un fiasco absolu et ça crée un
scandale en allemagne qui les rend
aujourd'hui très timide sur le sujet des
drones et puis il ya aussi quelque chose
qu'on dit - parce que c'est moins
avouables il faut bien reconnaître qu'il
ya une dizaine d'années où une quinzaine
d'années quand le les drones commencé à
se développer aux états unis un certain
nombre
de décideurs français militaires ou
autres ont cru que c'était un effet de
mode et n'ont pas voulu forcément
investir sur quelque chose qui dont on
se dira dont on n'envisageait pas
forcément la pérennité telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui
est ce qu'il ya une volonté politique
plus forte de certains partenaires
éventuellement les britanniques parce
que finalement on s'est entendu avec eux
pour développer ce futur f casse ce
futur système d'avions de combat il ya
quand même y ait des politiques mais
elle est effectivement elle est
contrainte par les arguments financiers
et on sent même si une volonté politique
on sent quand même pas que c'est un tel
impétueuse et une telle volonté que il
faut mettre ça au en priorité des
priorités et qu'il faut le résoudre
avant tout et une volonté politique
parmi d'autres et en groupe pour
l'instant chaque état est en train de
chercher sa solution en a chez en
interne comme l'afp comme l'a fait la
france avec les eau ont fait du projet
européen un peu en plus des solutions
internes parce que chacun deux pieds
donc un pied en s'équipant tout de suite
et un piano disant bond dans le futur on
va participer à un projet européen
on sait jamais mais je dirais qu'il n'ya
pas pour moi il n'ya pas la volonté
politique suffisante aujourd'hui pour
avancer très vite alors je peux me
permettre pour souligner renforcer ce
qui vient d'être dit c'est que l'année
dernière ce sont les industriels eux
mêmes qui ont pris l'initiative de dire
aux politiques bon il serait temps vous
mettiez d'accord parce que nous on est
prêts à faire justement
technologiquement d'assaut finmeccanica
airbus ont dit bon bah nous on est prêts
à faire des choses mais il faut qu'on
ait un peu de deux d'ordre politique
justement l'un d'eux de ces industriels
maître d'oeuvre d'une rond d'assaut le
pdg de dassault aviation à une question
à vous poser
écoutez
j'aurais souhaité vous poser une
question en tant qu'industriel français
et donc l'européen
comment voyez-vous le développement
de la défense en europe en l'absence de
souveraineté européenne
alors justement trois heures devant nous
on a quelques invités pour leur
traitement c'est une problématique qu
eric trappier connaît connaît bien et
nous sommes à un stade aujourd'hui en
europe où il faut qu'on prenne des
décisions
parce que si on les prend pas maintenant
on va disparaître de la carte
stratégique
on peut pas faire l'europe de la défense
ou une politique européenne de défense
passons au delà des débats sémantiques à
28 parce qu'il ya trop d'hétérogénéité
non seulement dans nos capacités mais
dans ce que nous voulons faire en commun
il ya des pays qui veulent pas qu'ils
ont pratiquement pas d'armé qui n'en
veulent pas il ya des pays qui veulent
pas intervenir à l'extérieur y en a
d'autres qui ont les moyens d'autres qui
les ont pas bref dans la seule solution
pour toi à très court terme
moi ce pourquoi je plaide fortement
c'est plus de flexibilité que ce qu'ils
veulent et qui peuvent
c'est à dire qu'ils ont à la fois la
volonté et les capacités et là il y en a
pas 28e vous dire qu on a fait deux ou
trois en europe quatre ou cinq on les
autorise les autres les autorise voir
les encourage il faudra peut-être
trouver des mécanismes de péréquation
financière
mais les encourage à aller de l'avant
que ce soit sur le plan capacitaire
c'est à dire des programmes ou sur le
plan opérationnel à l'extérieur alors
nicolas gros verheyde avec qui faire
l'europe de la défense ce finalement
lors de la défense et la france et
britanniques plus quelques autres
l'europe de la défense est pas la france
y britannique la france et les
britanniques c'est un projet
franco-britannique
les britanniques ne veulent pas d'europe
de la défense point il ne la feront
jamais ils ne veulent pas le mot europe
ils n'ont ils veulent bien de faire des
projets de coopération avec des pays
européens mais c'est les projets de
coopération bilatérale multilatérale
tout ce qu'on veut mais c'est pas
l'europe de la défense
c'est c'est pas les projets européens
donc ça c'est une leurs opérations
bilatérales s'étaient uru diverses et
variées haddock mais ce n'est pas
l'europe
ce qu'il faut surtout c'est pas le
moment même sur une opération anti
piraterie européenne les britanniques
qui est l'opération atalanta arrive à
mettre à dire que c'est une opération
multinationale ya quand même le mot
europe ne veulent pas donc ils sont
prêts à faire des temps jarrier
conditions on ne peut pas avancer avec
les britanniques non avec problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui chacun a des bloqueurs
avec les britanniques
ils veulent pas d'europe les allemands
sont son veulent pas trop dépenser non
plus et sont prêts à faire des projets
metz industriel mais pas très
opérationnelle du mois en mission de
combat à l'extérieur
les une dizaine de pays sont sous l'eau
en terme de budget donc le problème
c'est avec qui et donc c'est
effectivement on va avoir des une
succession de projets bilatéraux
multilatéraux qui auront un label
européen
c'est là dessus qu'on fera l'europe
donné dès france mais en même temps il
ya des besoins réels puisque aujourd'hui
on le voit les menaces n'ont jamais été
aussi proche de l'europe que donc que
dans le passé on est elles sont en plus
elle sait pas une menace en une
direction c'est pas comme les balkans
dans les années 90 où on avait un
problème en europe mais qui étaient
localisés là on a 5 6 menace aux
alentours alors on va vous donner le mot
de la fin
comment faire pour être présent sur tous
ces fronts avec avec l'europe de la
défense rejoins tout à fait ce que ce
que nicolas c'est à dire que aujourd'hui
j'allais dire peu importe l'étiquette
peu importe les procédures peu importe
que les britanniques veuillent pas le
mettre le mot europe ou pas il faut que
les états européens ceux qui veulent
faire des choses et qu'ils ont les
capacités de le faire sur le plan
industriel et ça sera pas forcément les
mêmes d'ailleurs on peut coopérer avec
l'italie sur le plan industriel même si
l'italie va être plus réticente à
s'engager à l'extérieur peu importe il
faut en l'air dans un tel état
aujourd'hui face à de telles menaces que
ce qu'ils veulent faire et qu'ils
peuvent faire pour les encourager à le
faire et le faire maintenant et le faire
de façon flexible pragmatique maintenant
et maintenant elles et les cision
politiques doivent être prises
maintenant questionner et surtout
concrètes parce que il faut arrêter les
grands débats il faut faut des projets
qui s'arrête on la théologie arrêtons la
théologie avance on avance on est bien
merci messieurs d'avoir été sur ce
plateau d' europe hebdo c'est la fin de
cette émission je vous donne rendez vous
la semaine prochaine et ce sera n'aura
hamadi qui sera aux commandes très bonne
suite de programmes sur lcp public sénat
bye bye
bon